hello everyone we are back at the
nation's cup with a really awesome game
from round seven it's pantala hari
krishna vs jorge cory
and it features the swashnekov uh and uh
well this game will will definitely show
us that it's not an easy opening to play
i myself started studying it a few days
ago
and it's it's really interesting it uh
gives black a lot of opportunities to
to fight for from from the start
but it can also be very dangerous which
which
may uh which we may uh witness here so
without further ado let's check it out
hari krishna opens with e4 sorry about
that
and we have c5 the sicilian defense uh
we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now d4 so just captures
captures
and now e5 uh immediately
uh going for that uh knight so not not
uh waiting for knight f6 knight c3 and
then e5 so basically uh the the
immediate e5 so it's a bit different
from the svershnikov
knight to b5 right away or maybe this is
also called the sweden cover i don't
know
i i don't think it is i think you first
have to develop the knights but it is
very interesting
we have d6 and now comes knight 1 to c3
uh we have a6 uh keying the knight back
and now after knight a3
pawn back upon is expanded to b5
threatening b4 to win one of the knights
so everything the same as in the
swesnikov or the last
sicilian or the the pelican if you
remember it that way
so knight to d5 and now knight to f6
so by by not uh going directly into it
maybe it's a way of
uh throwing black off guard if you know
that black is a swesnikov player
we have bishop to g5 now pinning the
knight and bishop to e7 now
uh now just uh uh removing the pin we
have bishop captures on f6 and
although sometimes you can capture with
the g pawn here bishop captures on f6
uh and uh now comes c4 so basically
we've just transposed into the normal
swashnikov
uh we have b for now challenging the
knight knight to c2 and now
rook to b8 you could also defend it with
a5 but here uh jorge cory goes for uh
b rook to b8 uh we have b3 now
and a5 uh and here white goes for g3
uh now the idea is to finger to the
bishop castle and then you can start
pushing f4 h4
or whatever you need we have castles by
corey and now
bishop to g2 just preparing the castle
uh and here uh we have g6 with the idea
of maybe
shifting the bishop over to g7 maybe
playing f5 in the future uh
maybe maybe bishop to g5 could also be
an idea not allowing this trait so maybe
then g6 but it does seem like
like it's a bit slow but you do prevent
f4 for for the moment at least
uh but okay we have g6 here and here uh
there is one game in the database where
queen to d3 was played but here we have
knight captures on f6 with
check and it is as a move 16 that we
have a completely new game
so queen captures an f6 and now we have
castles
uh so f4 will will come nicely in the
future queen back to e7 you don't work
your want your queen on the same file
and maybe black is also preparing f5 but
also you need to keep an eye on your d6
pawn
so here it doesn't seem like black got
all that
an impressive of a version of this
vegetable since he just
he will just be stuck guarding the d6
pawn pretty much forever
but okay queen e2 and then now bishop to
e6 black continues developing we have
rook
8 to d1 and now f6 strengthening the
center
but again you you've played f6 you you
better have a very good reason for it
so rook to d3 hari krishna will now
double up on the d
file put pressure on the backwards d6
pawn which is black's main weakness
and now knight the d8 preparing to shift
the knight over to b7 to add another
defender to the pawn
and now just rook f to d1 we have knight
to b7
defending it and now h4 white starts
expanding on the king's side
now we have rook after d8 adding another
defender
and now queen to d2 now maybe the queen
has some ideas of infiltrating on the on
the king side maybe a3 will be an idea
in the future going after the b4 pawn
uh we'll see we have king the g7
preventing queen to h6
and now knight to e3 and now from e3 the
knight can
uh that can come to d5 or maybe if you
can get
a f4 f5 and maybe the knight can come to
g4 then you put some uh
pressure on h6 again uh so black just
goes rook to d7 prepares to double up on
the d file so the knight can once again
be activated maybe via knight to c5
and hare krishna goes for f4 uh just
uh crashing through and it's not easy
for black to reply
for example uh you could go for
something like captures and then after
white recaptures go king h8 so if white
will be persistent with pushing f5 maybe
you can also get
the g file so you will somehow
activate your rooks however after this
f4 move we have rook beat
d8 by corey and now we have f5 by hari
krishna
and it's uh it's an extremely difficult
position for black so your bishop is
under attack you could capture it
and after pawn captures then move back
with the bishop
but corey decides to do it right away
and now we have f captures on g6 we have
h captures on g6
and now comes knight to g4 so the knight
finds its way to d
at the g4 uh no not much point in going
to d5
black will be very happy to just uh
remove that knight as his bishop isn't
all that impressive
uh and here you are already threatening
to jump in with the queen with queen to
h6 so here
uh again it's not easy to find a way
whatever you play let's say you move the
king or something to make way for the
queen to to block a queen h6 check
white will just go rook here and there's
no there's no
sorry not here maybe rook to f3 then
rook to f1
go after this pawn and it's going to be
it's going to be very difficult
uh to defend it for example if rook to
f8 you're just going to go queen to h6
check and then now not not really sure
what you'll do if you block with the
queen
then the rook falls so not really an
option so you'd have to block with the
bishop and after bishop to
at age seven now uh we we would get
pretty much
the position that we got into the game
so point is black went bishop to h7
first i'm not going to finish that line
since it's uh
i i think it's pretty much the same line
we got into the in the game
uh so here rook to f3 going after the f6
pawn and here rook to f8 defending it so
it is actually what happened in the game
uh so here uh hari krishna went queen to
h6 check we have king the h8 and
now white is completely lost uh so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolutely crushing move for white
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
very very uh sneaky tactic and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
knight captures on e5 uh and it was in
this position on move 31 that jorge kore
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
point is if you accept the the knight
for example with the f pawn then just
rook captures on f8 and the king has
nowhere to go it's game over
you cannot block with the bishop as it
spins so you'd have to give up your
queen here and that's just that
on the other hand if you capture with
this pawn then just rook captures on d7
if you move the queen it's queen
checkmate here
or here it doesn't really matter and if
you capture then the rook on f8 is no
longer defended
just queen captures with check bishop g8
and now you can pretty much do anything
captures with
check blocks and now you either trade
and play a
a much better end game or you can even
keep the queens on the board and
you're just up the exchange in a
completely winning position black's
position is completely
uh this destroyed
so uh lastly but not leastly you could
capture with the queen but then the rook
is just
immediately uh free for grabs which
means that uh okay maybe you can still
play it but not really after the bishop
blocks you're gonna go queen captures on
f6
and again it's uh just a much better
endgame white is up uh the exchange
and uh well yeah all of these pawns are
completely weak you're just gonna
win the game easily so uh like i said
animal 31 uh corey resigned and a great
victory for pentala hari krishna and pro
we're probably going to check out one
more game from round seven or eight
tomorrow and then we're going to discuss
the standings
uh so yeah i i don't know i uh i really
got interested in this whole sevesnikov
business and uh was really studying it
for the past two days
but it seems like uh when you play
against an extremely strong player
it's not all that easy to play but
that's the case with everything so
uh if any of you were also considering
uh you know maybe learning a bit about
the svechnikov maybe don't get
discouraged by this
uh by this seemingly easy win
from white as it is it is quite uh
quite difficult to learn uh but it does
offer you
a lot of a lot of fight uh so maybe
you'll find it interesting
and maybe when i'm done uh with uh
depending on how much i
i'm going to learn about it maybe i can
make a little video about it
to maybe uh [ __ ] some uh you know
ideas about it if you guys will be
interested
uh but yeah and once again i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
oliver choiceville uh thomas connors
dwight barkley uh abdul abdullah aziz
al masood uh and uh for katrina for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the
uh of the nation's cup and whatever else
i i manage the time for uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your friday